today we're announcing the introduction
of a new one-off 302
million pound recovery premium for state
primary
and secondary schools building on the
pupil premium
to further support pupils who need it
most
we're expanding our successful tutoring
programs 200 million
pounds will fund an extended national
tutoring program for primary and
secondary schools
an extension to the 16 to 19 tuition
fund
to support more students in english
maths and other vocational
and academic subjects and funding to
support language development
in early years children
finally 200 million pounds will be
available
for secondary schools to deliver
face-to-face summer schools
schools will be able to target
individual pupils needs
this means this if your child needs
extra help
then they will able to get it for
example
a block of tutoring can help a child
gain three to five months of catch up in
learning
we know our teachers are best placed to
understand what your children will need
so they'll have the tools to deliver
that
extra boost and make a real difference
as we recover from this pandemic
the package announced today will build
on the one billion pound catch-up
package we announced last june
and forms part of a wider response to
help pupils make up for
the lost learning they've suffered